With his arms down right below there.
Jamie on the bottom.
Bottom row.
Yeah.
That guy looks he's having a good time.
But that's a fun dude fucking party.
Super High.
Why the world needs happy men.
That's the what kind of fucking article is that?
I mean who wrote that?
Some depressed dude,
right about to shoot himself.
He's got a gun sitting on the desk right next to the laptops.
Like why the world needs happy man.
I'm trying to think of it right.
It's like,
yeah,
we'll come back guy.
That dude's fat.
That's,
Oh Bert wishes he was dead.
His kidney,
dangerous amount of berries.
Bird fucking loses all this weight.
Every year we do this weight loss thing.
Me Follow along.
You're crazy as to what?
The hot yoga and he fucking gains it all back every year.
Yeah.
Every year I saw him at soul cycle with his wife's fuck.
And he just,
I mean that's unbelievable.
He keeps telling me,
cause he sent,
he sent out a mass text test the other day that we have,
there's a group on my phone called the sober October group,
but it is one of the best text message threads ever.
It's ruthless.
Yeah,
it's Segura Ari,
me and Bert and uh,
and look at them.
Something's burning with Bert.
Kreischer that burn is not calories.
That's what's not burning.
No.
Um,
but he sent out this message of the day,
like I miss the heart rate monitors.
He's probably all drunk watching,
saving private Ryan.
So sad.
What the fuck am I doing?
Do you guys,
you guys talking without me?
What are you doing?
What's going on over there?
Hey guys,
I miss you guys.
I love Birdman.
He goes out,
he'll do a comedy club and then go out and tell everyone where he's going to
drink and then he meets them at the bar.
Takes the shirt off in Ottawa.
It's like 150 degrees below zero.
He drinks with the mall and then leaves.
Love you.
I love you.
Then he gets in his tour bus,
right?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't go to the second location,
you know,
I'll,
I'll hang out at the club a little bit,
take pictures of stuff,
but people,
and they have a beer,
but like when people are like,
hey,
you should go to our bar.
Nope.
Yeah,
I've done it in the past.
I used to in the past.
But after a while becomes untenable.
Yeah.
Well you can't,
cause you're,
you're playing like 5,000,
10,000 seaters now.
Yeah.
That's a lot of pictures.
You can't,
you're,
I watched,
I watched Jo Koy hanging out with where I'm like,
they're going to kill him.
Like they're going to,
they're going to tear his clothes off.
Like Elvis used to almost get shredded by female nails.
You know,
like,
there's so many people trying to get a selfie with him and he just played a
stadium and he's just outside.
Wow.
Just like,
dude,
just Joe,
just careful security.
Yeah.
He's got,
he's got some people with him for sure.
The tasers and whips.
Yeah.
Different guy.
Different,
uh,
different.
He has the,
there's like a lady Taser.
It's not as strong.
And there's like dude,
Taser for the various kinds of fans.
Yeah,
you gotta be careful,
but God bless him.
I mean that's kind of how he got that big.
The thing about Burt's fans is at Burt's fans were all drunk too,
right?
So they're probably not even going to know what to do or you don't remember if
they were going to kidnap him.
They give it up when they meet him yet the next day they checked their phone
like,
oh that's selfies all blurry and shit like yeah.
Well your hand was shaking from the dts while you tried to take it.
So coming back to town real quick,
give me a self,
your mirror selfie.
Come on.
Book tries to dress up my Facebook.
My wife's not talking to me.
Burden a,
your jokes in the only thing keeping me going and uh,
the heart's not too strong these days.
The doc doesn't say I have long,
so please don't come around writing this article for vox about why the world
needs happen.
Man.
You got three bullets in the chamber of Spanish once every six hours.
Russian rule.
That's one bullet,
not mine.
Boats.
Nah,
not Verne's not Verne's roulette mind with three bullets.